okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over gymnosperms and you know here's
a forest with with some gymnosperm trees
so let's go ahead and get started and
learn about their basic features okay so
we're gonna look at the third group of
plants if you've seen the other two
groups we're moving on to the seed
producing in the vascular plant so
there's really two categories of seed
producing vascular plants and one are
called gymnosperms and here we see a
cone a cone on probably a pine tree here
and you know pine is a great example of
a gymnosperm well you'll see what I mean
by those seeds are not covered by a
fruit as we go through this video
examples of gymnosperms will be cycad
would be gingko and Kota firs now we're
gonna mainly focus our attention today
on conifers but in another video and you
can browse through my video library if
you like eventually we'll talk more
about angiosperms and these are plants
whose seeds are covered by a fruit and
so gymnosperms and angiosperms these are
the two seed producing vascular plants
now this video is only going to cover
gymnosperms but like I said if you want
to learn more about the angiosperms I
have another video for that as well so
examples of angiosperms again you'll see
that in another video would be monocots
such as daffodils and dicots such as
apple apple trees so but let's go ahead
and focus our attention today on the
gymnosperms and before we give it a
gymnosperm x' specifically let's just
talk about seeds and their advantages so
whether it's a gymnosperm or angiosperm
they make seeds and seeds provide
advantages number one seed plants plants
that make seeds they don't depend on
water to reproduce the pictures that you
see here on top is a moss and on the
bottom is a fern and these are seedless
and moss and ferns need to live in moist
environments because they make sperm
cells that actually swim
through a layer of water in order to
fertilize the egg well the seeding
plants the gymnosperms and the anjali
angiosperms they don't rely on water to
reproduce so they produce pollen which
is often carried by wind or by animals
pollinating animals like the bumblebee
in the picture so because they don't
directly rely on water to reproduce it
allowed them to evolve elsewhere and
diversify over more habitats another
advantage of seeds is that there's
there's an embryo inside that seed that
has nourishment the embryo inside of
this seed has nutrition and nourishment
to feed upon until the seed cracks open
and the embryo of the seedling that
begins to do photosynthesis so the
embryo has nourishment the embryo also
has protection a hard shell so seeds
because they are hard and offers some
sort of protection give the embryo a
better chance of survival and seeds not
only do they offer the embryo a better
chance of survival but they allow the
embryo to be dispersed so seeds often
have wings now we're not implying that
the wings flap and produce flight it's
not that kind of wing but they often
will rotate and glide you may have heard
of helicopter seeds when they fall from
the tree they glide through the air and
they might land on the ground let's say
50 feet away from the parent tree by
landing away from the parent tree it
increases their odds of growing imagine
if I were to fall straight down and land
right beside or right underneath the
parent tree the parent tree already has
a head start and growth and would most
likely you know take all the nutrients
and the seeds that fell directly
underneath the tree probably wouldn't
wouldn't survive and wouldn't have the
resources needed to grow so by being
carried by the wind they're able to be
dispersed and not just wind but again
seed plans are
now we're looking at angiosperms right
here here's a bird you know eating some
berries and fruits and and eventually
the seeds will be dispersed in a new
location and what do I mean by dispersed
well the seeds will most likely pass
through the digestive tract of the
animal and then will be deposited or
pooped out in another location so let's
actually look at the gymnosperms I want
to mention the category called conifers
or conifers so conifers conifers these
are a type of gymnosperm and these are
the ones we're going to focus our
attention on today conifers one of their
defining characteristics are their
needle-like leaves and it helps to
reduce water loss many of these grow in
cold environments and so having big
broad flat leaves like you see in warmer
forests well if if conifers had big
broad flat leaves well they probably
lose too much water through evaporation
and so by having needle-like leaves it
reduces their water loss which is really
important considering they go for months
without rain so kkona furs are quite
common to the lumber industry so the
wood is used for building materials it
typically comes from Kota furs Kota furs
Warrnambool one of the way they get
their names conifers is they reproduce
with cones now there are different types
of cones there are male cones which are
called pollen cones and like the name
implies male pollen cones produce pollen
and then there are what are called
female seed cones and notice how the two
cones look quite different so the female
seed cones look more woody and you know
these are the cones that were used to
seeing if you've ever you know just gone
on a hike and you see cones that have
fallen and landed on the ground so the
male pollen cones produce pollen the
female seed cones produce eggs and
eventually seeds and we're going to get
into that process in just a few moments
and so conifers eventually when they
produce seeds there's embryos inside of
those seeds and here's a person kind of
shaking a cone and you can see scenes
have fallen onto the the table that the
person has shaken the cone over and so
inside of those seeds are little embryos
that can hopefully crack open and begin
to grow and grow into a full-grown
perhaps evergreen tree so evergreen is
one example pine red wood cedar these
are all examples of Kona firs so when we
look at the cone of her lifecycle okay
if you recall plants alternate between
diploid and haploid stage this
alternation of generations and if you
remember the diploid stage is what we
call the sporophyte stage so here's a
mature adult sporophyte you know pine
tree and and industry's been growing for
decades in a forest pretend well notice
how there are male pollen cones on the
left of the tree and there's a female
seed cone on the right of the tree now
in reality there's multiple pollen cones
and multiple seed cones but for
simplicity I've only drawn one of each
here so if we focus our attention on the
male pollen code so male pollen cones
are going to will create micro spores
through the process of meiosis and so
micro spores are haploid and microspores
represent the gametophyte stage so the
micro spores will ultimately develop
into pollen pollen grains and here's a
magnified image of a pollen grain and so
again micro spores and pollen are the
male gametophyte because these are the
haploid stages of the life of a plant or
of a of a conifer and so ultimately this
pollen will be released into the air and
you notice how the pollen grain even has
two little wing structures near the top
of the picture that kind of help it
glide a little bit through the air and
so in my animation here we have a male
pollen cone releasing pollen into the
air okay well we'll follow that pollen
in just a moment
so before we follow that power let's now
focus our attention on the seed cones
the female seemed
so if we zoom on into a female seed cone
where we see are these these when the
seed comes open there are these long
gaps these are these little individual
branches of a seed corner called scales
and so if we kind of look at one scale
let's zoom on in to one scale and when
we zoom on in here we have one single
scale and inside of of each individual
scale here is a mega spore that will
grow through the process and that is
created through the process of meiosis
and so I've highlighted the female
megaspore and again ultimately this
becomes this is the female gametophyte
this is the haploid stage in the life of
a conifer and inside of that gray circle
that I've labeled the female gametophyte
there's an egg egg waiting to be and so
through the process of pollination that
egg will eventually become fertilized
and so here comes a male pollen green
notice that there's a black dot in the
middle so that orange circle is our male
pollen grain and that black dot in the
middle is the sperm cell that's inside
of the pollen grain and so what
ultimately happens is a pollen tube will
begin to grow towards the egg and in
reality this may take months to grow
only a few millimeters perhaps but
ultimately a pollen tube will grow from
the sperm or excuse me a pollen tube
will grow from the pollen and penetrate
into the female gametophyte okay so now
we've set up fertilization where the
sperm and the egg will fuse together to
make a zygote so the power tube has
grown and now that the pollen tube has
grown that sperm cell will travel down
the pollen tube into the megaspore which
is again the female gametophyte and
therefore the sperm and the egg will
fuse fertilization will occur and a
zygote will form now over time the
zygote will then
to divide and grow into an embryo that's
what we see in the animation right there
with the green structure is the embryo
well also as time goes on the
surrounding seed coat begins to harden
into a protective seed with the embryo
trapped on the inside well now if we
zoom back out to that seed cone that we
saw a few moments ago you'll notice that
in every individual scale there is now a
seed again assuming that pollination and
fertilization were successful in every
scale there is now a seed so when the
cone opens multiple seeds will be
released from one single cone and
ultimately the seeds will be released
and will hopefully grow into a young
sporophyte which will repeat this whole
process so here we have our our tree
with the this the female seed cone and
we see little helicopter seeds are being
released from from the cone well you
know let's go follow let's go follow one
of those seeds that just fluttered out
of the seed cone and when we do here it
comes
and eventually the females excuse me
eventually this the seed lands the
helicopter seed lands on the ground and
over time over time a young sporophyte
begins to grow and as the years go by it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger until
eventually it reaches the age of sexual
maturity where it too produces pollen
cones and seed cones to restart the
whole process so there you go there's a
brief overview a brief description of
gymnosperms and and the lifecycle of
conifers so if you're in my biology
class go ahead and pause the video and
try to answer these questions I'd be
happy to check your answers for accuracy
either before school or after school one
day so good luck